ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL ALL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ IS [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS COURT
[inaudible]
SILVA.
RAMOS.
RAMOS THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
[inaudible]
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY
OSHITA.
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
I'M NOT SIX WEEKS AGO AT THE
VERY END OF APRIL MY HUSBAND
BOBBY KNIGHT CARVED OUT A FOUR
DAY GETAWAY TO BANFF CANADA.
IT WAS A PLACE I LONG WANTED TO
VISIT.
WE LEFT NINETY DEGREE SACRAMENTO
AND WE WERE GREETED BY SNOW
FLURRIES IN THIS MODEL HI TOWN
NESTLED IN THE CANADIAN ROCKIES.
THE AMAZING VIEW OF THE TREES IN
THE MOUNTAINS SURROUNDING US ALL
DUSTED WITH SNOW WAS
BREATHTAKING.
AND ALTHOUGH IT WAS TWENTY TWO
DEGREES.
THE THOUGHT THE KIND AND THOUGHT
SPIRIT OF THE PEOPLE THERE
WARMED OUR HEARTS HE MADE US
FEEL AS IF WE WERE BEING
WELCOMED HOME.
AFTER VERY PLEASANT CHECK IN.
OUR ROOM PHONE RANG.
IT WAS THE MANAGEMENT ASKING IF
WE WERE PLEASED WITH OUR
ACCOMMODATIONS AND IF WE NEEDED
ANYTHING MORE.
THIS WAS A FIRST FOR US.
THEN ARMED WITH HOTEL PROVIDED
BUS PASSES.
WE VENTURED INTO THE IMMACULATE
TOWN A BAN.
WE WERE AMONG THE FEW PEOPLE
STANDING FOR THE SHORT TEN
MINUTE RIDE.
BUT ALMOST IMMEDIATELY TO
YOUNGER ADULTS MALE AND FEMALE
STOOD UP AND OFFERED US THEIR
SEATS.
THAT TOO WAS THE FIRST BREATH.
WE RELUCTANTLY ACCEPTED THEIR
CON OFFERS.
HEALING BOTH GRATEFUL AND
SUDDENLY ELDERLY.
ON OUR TRIP IT FELT AS IF AGAIN
AND AGAIN WE WERE THE RECIPIENTS
OF UNEXPECTED KINDNESS OF I'M
FAMILIAR WITH THE ALL WAY
CROSSING INTERSECTIONS. ONE KIND
STRANGER LITERALLY POLL BOB'S
ARM BACK PREVENTING HIM FROM
STEPPING OUT IN FRONT OF A CAR
TURNING THE CORNER.
WITHOUT THIS IF THE PEOPLE OF
BAM WE'RE ALL AMBASSADORS OF
CARING AND KINDNESS.
AND THEY REPRESENTED THEIR TOWN
SO VERY WELL.
IT WAS A TRIP THAT WE ENJOYED SO
MUCH THERE WE ARE ALREADY
LOOKING FORWARD TO RETURNING.
AS BOB AND I HAVE SAID TO EACH
OTHER BEFORE.
WHENEVER WE ENCOUNTER REAL
KINDNESS A PART OF US FEELS AYE
CHO LIVE HERE.
ALL OF US WE TO OUR AMBASSADORS
ON MANY LEVELS.
IN OUR WORDS IN OUR ACTIONS
ESPECIALLY TOWARDS STRANGERS
WILL BE A REFLECTION ON OUR
FAMILIES OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
LEGISLATURE ARE AMAZING STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR COUNTRY.
WHEN IT BE WONDERFUL IF WE ARE
ALL AMBASSADORS A WARM HEARTED
KINDNESS?
IF WE WERE.
WE WOULD HELP MAKE OUR WORLD THE
VERY BEST PLACE TO LIVE.
NOW MOMMY NUMBER TWO WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER CELLS.
THANK YOU READY SALUTE PLEDGE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
BY.
A STATE WHERE [inaudible]
AND INDIVISIBLE WITH.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY
NINE TWENTY NINETEEN THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT TEN AM I'LL
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF
COOKIE DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING CLERK KAPLAN AND LOUIS
READING THE WORLD MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MR FLORA
SECONDS THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BILL ROE.
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
KANSEN CHU MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT ALLOW SOMETHING
MEMBERS BIGELOW JONES SAWYER AND
O'DONNELL TO HAVE GUESTS.
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
WILL HAVE HIS GAS AT HIS DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
THE SPEAKER IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER TO SPEAK ON IN THE
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE MCGUIRE FROM
THE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE SB TWO
FIFTY THREE DOT FROM AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE TO AN AFTER RESOURCE
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN MONEY FROM
YOUR CULTURE COMMITTEE TO THE
BUSINESS OF PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
AND SB SEVEN SIXTEEN MITCHELL
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
TO THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
DOCTOR CHOI FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DRESSER.
YOUR SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE TO
FIFTY ONE I MOTION TO REFER
ASSEMBLY BE IT A TEN NINETY FOUR
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU TAXES ROY THAT'S A
MOTION TO REFER THAT REQUIRES A
SECOND.
SECONDED BY MISTER MATHIS WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND ON THE ON
THE FLOOR.
AFTER CHOI YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
TO THE PROPRIETY OF THE
REFERENCE.
OKAY THE RULES COMMITTEE -- HAS
NOT TAKEN ACTION ON THIS BILL TO
STOP THE USE OF TAXPAYER MONEY
BEING USED TO IN THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SETTLEMENTS ARE IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
THE OPTICAL DOCTOR TRAIN AND I
REMIND YOU PLEASE SPEAK TO THE
PROPRIETY OF THE REFERRAL ON THE
BILL.
NOT ON THE MERITS THEMSELVES OF
SPEAK TO THE PROPRIETY OF THE
THE REFERENCE.
I WOULD LIKE -- TO ASCO TO MOVE
IT TO THE MEDIA THAT WERE TAKEN
ACTION ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
ON BEHALF OF A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
VICTIMS.
THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND ON
THE FLOOR THIS A MOTION RE REFER
TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES MEMBERS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE IN THIS CASE
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
NO.
THOUGH DOCTOR CHOI IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE THIS IS PROCEDURAL
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
NO.
VOTE.
DOCTOR CHOI IS ASKING FOR AN EYE
DOCTOR CHOICE ASKING FOR AN I.
MISTER CALDERON I KNOW.
THIS TAKES.
FORTY ONE ON THE MOTION TO RE
REFER.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL TAKES
FORTY
ONE CLOSER ROLLING TIE THAT EYES.
FIFTEEN KNOWS FORTY TWO THAT
MOTION FAILS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW. FOR HIS
RESOLUTION FROM MY DESK IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER MR BIGELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MEMBERS ARE RISE TO
INTRODUCE MADERA HIGH SCHOOLS
MATT TOWN ROBOTICS TEAM.
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE THEY WERE
RANKED NUMBER ONE IN THE WORLD
AND MATT TOWN ROBOTICS TOOK HOME
FIRST PLACE IN THIS YEAR'S VERY
FIRST ROBOTICS CHAMPIONSHIP HELD
IN HOUSTON TEXAS.
THIS IS NO SMALL FEAT THEY
COMPETE ON A HUGE LEVEL WITH
PEOPLE FROM ACROSS THE WORLD.
MEMBERS.
THE MAN -- BUT THERE OF THAT
TOWN ROBOTICS TEAM HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE AND THIS
MENTOR BASED PROGRAM THE BILL
SCIENCE ENGINEERING AND
TECHNOLOGY SKILLS.
PLEASE GIVE A BIG WELCOME TO
MADERA.
HIGH SCHOOLS VERY ON THAT TOWN
ROBOTICS TEAM THIRTEEN TWENTY
THREE UP IN THE GALLERY OUR SON
AND I'LL INTRODUCE IN A MOMENT
THOSE BEHIND ME.
PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM ROUND OF
APPLAUSE.
MR BIGELOW YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ADDITIONAL I HAVE WITH ME ON THE
FLOOR ADVISER BURN DOWN MONTY.
AND IN THE GALLERY MENTOR RAJI
KAJOL ALONG WITH FIVE TEAM
REPRESENTATIVES TO ACCEPT THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING THEM FOR
THEIR OUTSTANDING ACHIEVEMENT.
AGAIN LET'S GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR THIS TREMENDOUS
ACCOMPLISHMENT REPRESENTING NOT
JUST CALIFORNIA NOT JUST MADERA
COUNTY BUT THE ENTIRE WORLD HERE
TODAY
ATTENTION.
MISTER JONES SAWYER HAS A COUPLE
OF VERY SPECIAL.
GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS
[inaudible]
MR.
JONES SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
TODAY FOR THE FIRST TIME ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR -- FLIRTING WITH
ALL THE WOMEN IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY IS MY GRANDSON.
AARON RONALD JONES SAWYER MAKE
NOW THE JUNIOR.
THAT'S ALL WE IN OUR FAMILY
LEARNED ALPHABET BY VERY VERY
LONG NAMES.
ALSO WITH ME TODAY IS MY
DAUGHTER WHO JUST -- CROSSED
OVER ACROSS THE BURNING SANDS OF
DELTA SIGMA THETA SORORITY.
INGLEWOOD ALUMNI CHAPTER WITH ME
WITH HER SON TODAY.
AND I ALSO LIKE THIS BIG MAKE A
SPECIAL INTRODUCTION.
OF DELTA SIGMA THETA SORORITY --
MY DAUGHTER IS A PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER.
SHE GRADUATED IN MATH.
SHE COULD HAVE GONE INTO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR KNOBS YOU MADE A
GOBBLED MONEY -- PROBABLY HELP
ME RETIRE.
BUT PUBLIC SERVICE WAS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO HER.
AS THE MEMBERS OF DELTA SIGMA
DATA FOUNDED IN.
NINETEEN THIRTEEN THE MEMBERS OF
DELTA SIGMA THETA ARE HERE TODAY
AND AS YOU SEE UP IN THE GALLERY
AND AS MY MY GRANDSON WAS WAVING
TO ALL THE LADIES IN THE IN THE
GALLERY.
THE ORGANIZATION IS THE
SISTERHOOD OF PREDOMINANTLY
BLACK.
COLLEGE EDUCATED WOMAN WITH THE
MISSION OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
ALUMNI OF THIS ORGANIZATION
INCLUDE DOROTHY HEIGHT.
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF NEGRO WOMEN.
BARBARA JORDAN THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO SERVE IN
CONGRESS FROM THE SOUTH.
RUBY DEE.
DAVIS EXTRAORDINARY FILM AND
TELEVISION ACTRESS YOU WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THEY HERE TODAY FOR
THE HERE TODAY FOR DEL TODAY.
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO CALL
AND LET YOU KNOW WHAT THE
PRIORITIES ARE NOT ONLY FOR THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY BUT
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEY COME FROM DIFFERENT
CHAPTERS ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING SACRAMENTO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND MIDDLE CALIFORNIA.
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU SOME REALLY REMARKABLE
MEMBERS OF THE DELTA SORORITY.
ONE TRACY ATKINS PARECE REGIONAL
DIRECTOR. TWO LEONA BRIDGE.
YOUR WAY TO LIKE. TO ALL THE
INTRODUCTION.
LEONA BRIDGES MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL SOCIAL ACTION COMMITTEE.
THREE SHELLY GOT CHERYL BELLY I
SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN THAT.
WRONG WE WENT TO SCHOOL TOGETHER.
SHE HAS INFORMATION ON ME THAT
I'VE NEVER WON OUT CHAU GALLEY
COURT COORDINATOR THE FAR WEST
REGIONAL SOCIAL ACTION COMMITTEE.
FOR THIS LINDA WHITE PRESIDENT
OF HERE SACRAMENTO ALUMNI
CHAPTER AND FINALLY COULD TRINA
DUNN CO CHAIR OF THE SACRAMENTO
ALUMNI SOCIAL ACTION COMMITTEE.
ALSO IN THE BALCONY WE HAVE
SEVENTY MEMBERS OF WHAT THEY
CALL THE RED ARMY IN THE
AUDIENCE MEMBERS PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME THEM TO THE CAPITAL
TODAY.
AND DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZED YES MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I TO WANT TO WELCOME
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
DELTA HERE -- THE DOCTORS TO THE
CAPITAL AND I WAS REMINDED
EVERYONE HERE AND AS SOME OF YOU
MAY NOT WORK WORK HERE WITH THE
A. K. AS WE HEAR THE OTHER WEEK.
IS THAT THE UNIQUE THING ABOUT
BLACK SORORITIES AND
FRATERNITIES.
THE REGULAR SORORITIES AND
WHERE YOUR LIFE AND YOUR
IMPORTANCE IS ON THE COLLEGE
CAMPUS?
OUR ACT ARE SORORITIES AND
FRATERNITIES BECOME FAR MORE
ACTIVE AFTER GRADUATION THAN
DOING GRADUATION.
THE ALUMNI CHAPTERS ARE THE ONES
THAT REALLY DRIVE THE SOCIAL AND
THE ECONOMIC PROGRAMS OF BLACK
COMMUNITIES AND SO WE SHOULD
NEVER CONFUSE THEM BECAUSE I
WHEN I WAS AT UCLA THERE WERE
LOTS OF LOTS OF SORORITIES AND
FRATERNITIES.
AND WHEN SCHOOL ENDED WHEN THEY
GRADUATED BECAME A STATUS THING
AND THAT WAS IT.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE IN A BLACK
SORORITY OR FRATERNITY IT IS A
FUN GRADUATION THAT'S A REAL
SERVICE ACTUALLY BEGIN.
AS THESE ORGANIZATIONS ARE POWER
HOUSES IN BLACK COMMUNITIES AND
SO I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT SO
THAT YOU DON'T GET IT CONFUSED
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE FOLKS.
WHO REALLY RUN THE SOCIAL AND
THE AND ECONOMIC PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHO RESCUE OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR FAMILIES IN
SOME VERY UNIQUE WAY THE SONG
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IS THE
CHAIR OF THAT?
I WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO THE
CAPITAL AND FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE. ONE REMAINING
VERY SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION
AND I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
MISTER O'DONNELL FROM MY DESK IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
MR O'DONNELL YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
ON MAY FOURTH FOUR TEAMS
COMPETED IN LONG BEACH FOR THE
NC DOUBLE A MEN'S VOLLEYBALL
CHAMPIONSHIP.
WELL EVERY TEAM PERFORMED
ADMIRABLY ONLY ONE WOULD EMERGE
VICTORIOUS AND THAT IS LONG
BEACH STATE.
I AM A LONG AND I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE FROM WINNERS IN A LINE
ITEM OF A COLLEAGUE SOMEWHERE
AROUND HERE FROM SAKARA RENTAL
WHO'S AN ALUMNI AS WELL.
IN THE FINAL ROUND THE LONG
BEACH STATE FORTY NINE DEFEATED
THE DEFEATED THE UNIVERSITY OF
WISE RAINBOW WARRIORS TO WIN THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP. FOR THE
SECOND YEAR IN A ROW.
TODAY WE ARE JOINED BY PLAYERS
AND COACHES FROM CSU LONG BEACH
IS MEN'S VOLLEYBALL PROGRAM A
CHAMPIONSHIP PROGRAM.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING AND
CONGRATULATING THESE CHAMPIONS
WE HAVE BEHIND ME PLAYERS CARLOS
DANIEL RIVER OF A GUN.
AND ALEXANDER NICHOLAS HONEST
TOSSES ADIOS.
I HOPE BY SAID THAT CORRECTLY.
AND COACH AYE ALLEN NIGHT.
AND ASSISTANT COACH ANNETTE BUT
GRAY YOU MAY KNOW HIS FATHER
BRUCE TO SOMEWHERE AROUND THIS
BUILDING TODAY.
AND ATHLETIC DIRECTOR ANDY FEE --
MEMBERS -- THE THE INDIVIDUAL
BEHIND ME MAKE LONG BEACH
PROBABLY MAKE OUR CSU SYSTEM
PROUD AND THEY MAKE CALIFORNIA
PROUD THEY ARE CHAMPIONS GIVE
THEM A WARM WELCOME AND A
CONGRATULATORY CALL
.
HI MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING CORKERY.
SENATE BILL FORTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ON RECONSIDERATION ITEMS
TWO AND THREE ARE TO BE
CONTINUED.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
ITEMS FOUR THROUGH NINE PASS AND
RETAIN AND ON THE THIRD READING
FILE. FOR THE SENATE.
BILLS SENATE THIRD READING FILE
ITEMS TEN THROUGH.
FOURTEEN ALSO PASS AND RETAIN.
AS WE DO HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL THREE FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY THE
ELDERS INDEPENDENT TO ADULTS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS VOTE. TO DECIDE ABOUT
.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED ABOUT
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE ISEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT.
SENATE BILL.
TWO THIRTY TWO I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO MEMBERS WE ARE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS AND NOW SPANS DEMOCRATS
WILL BE CAUCUS SAYING IN THE
LOUNGE UPON ADJOURNMENT.
DEMOCRATS THERE WILL BE A CAUCUS.
IN THE LOUNGE UPON ADJOURNMENT.
OF SESSION.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JUNE ELEVENTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY.
JUNE TWELFTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY JUNE THIRTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION UPON CALL OF THE SPEAKER.
FRIDAY JUNE FOURTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION.
UPON CALL OF THE SPEAKER.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS A
QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
AND PLEASE.
GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION
DEAR COLLEAGUES.
IF YOU MUST PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS.
MISTER GALLAGHER HERE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS THE FOOD ON OUR TABLE IS
BROUGHT ABOUT BY THE HARD WORK
OF MANY IN AGRICULTURE. ONE
IMPORTANT SEGMENT IS OUR CROP
DUSTERS.
PILOTS IN LOW FLYING AIRCRAFT
THE PROVIDE FOR THE SEATING OF
CROPS.
AND THE SPRAYS THAT PROTECT THEM
FROM DISEASE.
IT IS A JOB THAT REQUIRES GREAT
SKILL AND PRECISION AND
PRECISION IN THE AIR.
IT CAN ALSO BE VERY DANGEROUS.
AS THESE PILOTS MUST OFTEN DEAL
WITH POWER LINES AND CHANGING
WEATHER CONDITIONS.
LAST MONTH ON MAY FIFTEENTH THIS
POINT HIT ALL TOO CLOSE TO HOME.
AS WE LOST TWO OF THESE AMAZING
PILOTS OVER THE SKIES OF SUTTER
COUNTY.
THESE WERE OUR FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS AND A SMALL CLOSE KNIT
COMMUNITY.
TODAY MEMBERS ASSET WE REMEMBER
THEM AND AS WE DO.
I ALSO ASKED WE REMIND OURSELVES
OF THE GREAT WORK AND SACRIFICE
THAT GOES INTO PRODUCING
[inaudible]
OUR FOOD [inaudible]
BURKE HALLWAY.
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF FIFTY
EIGHT IN A TRAGIC ACCIDENT DOING
WHAT HE LOVED.
FLYING HIS WHITE AND RED AG CAT
SEE MODELED CROP DUSTER AIRCRAFT.
BIRD WAS BORN ON OCTOBER
ELEVENTH NINETEEN SIXTY AND YUBA
CITY TO MOW AND IRENE HùI.
HE GREW UP AND SPENT HIS ENTIRE
LIFE IN THE EPICENTER AREA.
AND BOY WAS IT A FUN LIFE FOR
BIRD.
FLYING WAS BIRDS PASSION.
AT THE AGE OF SIXTEEN HE
RECEIVED HIS PRIVATE PILOT'S
LICENSE.
AND AT THE AGE OF TWENTY FOUR HE
RECEIVED HIS COMMERCIAL AD PILOT
LICENSE.
HE WAS THE OWNER OF MOWS CROP
DUSTING SERVICE CO OWNER OF THE
RED HILLS SALOON AND A RICE
FARMER.
VIRTUAL -- HARD WORK -- BIRDS
WORK HARD AND PLAY HARDER.
MENTALITY LED HIM TO HUNTING IN
ARGENTINA MEXICO IDAHO WYOMING.
AND OTHER PLACES WITH HIS GUY
BODIES.
ANOTHER LOVE WAS CRUISING THE
LAKES WAKE BOARDING.
LISTEN TO MUSIC.
AND DRINKING A BEER ON HIS BOAT
WITH MANY FRIENDS THE LAPORTE
CABIN AND SNOW SNOWMOBILING ALSO
ADDED TO HIS FAVORITE ACTIVITIES.
HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS QUICK WIT.
AND IS KIND AND COMPASSIONATE
SPIRIT.
BROUGH BELONG TO MANY
ASSOCIATIONS AND BOUGHT MANY AN
ANIMAL AT THE JUNIOR LIVESTOCK
AUCTION.
IN PLASTER AND THE YUBA SUTTER
COUNTY FAIRS.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER
IRENE DATIN.
HIS BROTHER GARY H<c.cyan> GRIMES</c>
JIM DUTTON.
CANDACE PRICE CINDY MENDEZ AND
FAMILIES.
BIRD IS ALSO SURVIVED BY THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE BEST FRIEND.
AND BUSINESS PARTNER OF THIRTY
ONE YEARS RINA SCHEIBER
[inaudible]
WE WENT.
BRIAN JULIAN VANDYKE.
SIXTY TWO ALSO PASSED AWAY ON
THAT FATEFUL DAY.
HE WAS TRAGICALLY TAKEN FROM
THIS LIFE DOING WHAT HE LOVES SO
IN RYE SEED IN HIS DE MODEL
LAGGED CAT OVER HIS FAMILY'S
RANCH.
BRIAN WAS BORN NOVEMBER
FIFTEENTH NINETEEN FIFTY SIX IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA TO DEAN
AND DONNA VANDYKE.
HE WAS THE YOUNGEST OF THREE
BROTHERS.
HE GREW UP IN PLEASANT GROVE
CALIFORNIA WHERE HE DEVELOPED A
DEEP LOVE FOR FARMING.
WHILE WORKING WITH HIS DAD AND
POP ON THE FORM.
BRIAN GRADUATED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR FROM EAST NICOLAS
HIGH SCHOOL MY ALMA MATER.
HE WAS CAPTAIN OF THE FOOTBALL
TEAM IN CLASS PRESIDENT HE WAS A
BRIGHT LIGHT.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL HE ATTENDED
CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO
CONTINUED ON TO CHICO STATE.
HE GRADUATED FROM THIS YEAR
ACADEMY OF AERONAUTICS IN
OAKLAND IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT TO PURSUE A CAREER IN
AVIATION.
HE BEGAN WORKING ALONGSIDE HIS
FATHER AND TWO BROTHERS AND
EVENTUALLY FOUNDED.
THE RAFTER Vì RANCH.
WHERE HE SPENT THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS?
OF HIS LIFE.
BRIAN LOVED ANYTHING THAT
INVOLVES SPEED.
BRIAN ENJOYED WATER SKIING HOT
RODS AND CRUISING ON HIS
MOTORCYCLE.
HE WAS A CAR NOT.
HE HAD A GREAT MIND AND SKILL
FOR WELDING AND FABRICATING.
INNOVATIVE FARMING IMPLEMENTS
ONE I REMEMBER MOST IS A HUGE
SPRAY BLOOM.
THERE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND.
IN RICE COUNTRY.
HE LOVED HUNTING AND THE
OUTDOORS.
IS WHERE HE LOVED TO BE THE BEST
WEATHER DOT COUNTING ON HIS
RANCH GOOSE HUNTING IN CANADA.
DOVE HUNTING TO MEXICO BIG GAME
HUNTING IN MONTANA AND COLORADO.
AND FISHING IN BAJA.
HE WAS AN AWARD WAITING HE WAS
AN AWARD WINNING TRAP SHOOTER
SPRINT CAR RACER.
OFF ROAD RACER AND DESERT RACER.
BUT MOST OF ALL.
BRIAN WAS A LOVING FATHER
[inaudible]
UNCLE [inaudible]
BROTHER [inaudible]
AND GRANDFATHER.
HE AND JENNY REYES FOUR AMAZING
KIDS.
CASEY BRANDON SETH AND FOREST.
AS WE SHARE TO HIS FUNERAL.
THEY ALL CARRY THE BEST
QUALITIES OF BRIAN.
EACH OF THEM HAS A LOVE FOR
FAMILY AND THEY CONTINUE HIS
LEGACY OF CARS FLIGHT AND
FABRICATING.
HE WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED AND
ALWAYS REMEMBERED.
BRIAN IS SURVIVED BY HIS
CHILDREN OF THIS SET IS OLDER
BROTHERS ROBERT AND GERRY.
HIS BELOVED SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN
CREWS CAN IN WESTON VIVIAN BEAU
HENRY ANTI.
FOREVER FLYING STRAIGHT WITH NO
SKIPS.
GENTLEMEN WE SALUTE YOU.
AND WE WILL MISS YOU.
GOD SPEED.
THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY.
OF FOUR YOUNG MEN FROM THE CITY
OF B<c.cyan> WHO ARE CLOSE IN AGE</c>
AND CLOSE IN KINSHIP.
WHO SANTA MONICA SHYAM AGE
TWENTY HUSSEIN YES AIR SOB?
AGE.
TWENTY FOUR HUSSEIN WAS ARE YOU.
TWENTY TWO HUSSEIN ALI SOLEIL
AGE.
TWENTY TWO ALL DIED LAST MONTH
IN A SINGLE TRAGIC ACCIDENT.
THE DESK TOOK PLACE IN THE EARLY
MORNING HOURS AFTER CEREMONY IN
THE MIDST OF THE OBSERVATION.
OF THE ISLAMIC HOLY MONTH OF
RAMADAN.
INSTEAD OF A JOYOUS AND TO THE
FAST IT TO THE TO THE FASTING
MONTH.
THE LEBANESE COMMUNITY IN MY
DISTRICT HAS BEEN FORCED INTO
DEEP MOURNING.
AND HUNDREDS HAVE GATHERED TO
HONOR THE VICTIMS.
WHEN WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF A
CALIFORNIA IT IS USUALLY IN
RECOGNITION OF THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS?
AND TO HONOR WHAT THEY GAVE TO
THEIR COMMUNITY.
TODAY HOWEVER WE MUST MOVE MORE
IN THE GREAT THINGS THAT THESE
FOUR MEN WHO ARE JUST ENTERING
THEIR PRIME.
CANNOT ACCOMPLISH IT IS A LOSS
TO US ALL.
AND I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN THEIR
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF THE DEATHS WE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO GERMAN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING HER NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
THIS FEATURE DOORS MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
UNTIL THURSDAY.
UPON CALL OF THE SPEAKER.
AND THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED